Speaker 1: One last Jorge Santos slash Anthony
divulged their story. George Santos is now the
target of three ethics complaints over his
campaign spending, his campaign fundraising
and his financial disclosure. Business Insider
and Brian Metzger have a piece about this. The
left leaning advocacy group and Citizens United is
going to be filing three ethics complaints against
Jorge Santos alleging campaign finance violations
and adding to a number of other complaints.
The group's complaint with the Department
of Justice argues Santos violated the Ethics
in Government Act, but not by not only filing a
required financial disclosure almost a year late,
but also most likely making several omissions
related to assets he's purported to hold. The
complaint with the Office of Congressional Ethics
argues that he violated federal law by soliciting
campaign contributions in exchange for attending a
swearing in event on Capitol grounds. Last month,
his team advertised roundtrip bus tickets from New
York to D.C., a lunch and attendance at Santos,
his swearing in, and a tour of the Capitol. If you
donate, at least 100 bucks, federal law prevents
the use of official resources in connection with
campaign activity. Huh? That's disappointing,
isn't it? The group's complaint with the FEC
focuses on a purported $700,000 personal loan that
he made to his campaign that the group says either
came from a shell company or was a prohibited
corporate contribution. You can read about the
details of each of each of these complaints.
This is you know, this is a very important guy.
At the end of the day, George Santos is the
first person to ever walk across the Pacific
Ocean. He can turn Mountain Dew into liquid
silver. And obviously, I'm kidding. And this is
a very, very bad start for George Santos. It is
increasingly clear that the Republican Party
is panicking, but only because it looks bad
they don't actually care about this guy being
a liar. McCarthy has still not even made any
criticisms. It appears as though there's some kind
of you know, I'm not saying it's illegal bribery,
but just a sort of quid pro quo. Santos pledged
to support McCarthy for speaker, and McCarthy
maybe pledged not to suggest that Santos should
resign. That at least seems to be holding true
for the time being. We'll see if it changes. But
Republicans only care about this in so far as it's
damaging their credibility. I hope Santos resigns.
Let's hope by Monday he's gone. All of these clips
will be on our Instagram, which you can find
by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.